we've been using the iPhone 15 lineup
for the last couple of weeks since
launch and even though this is a great
upgrade this year they definitely have
some problems and I know you guys are
saying that we're Apple Shields we're
going to defend Apple to the death but
in this video we are going to go through
the top 10 problems after 2 weeks now
with that said let's get into problem
number one which is actually one of my
favorite Parts about it which is the new
titanium Metal finish and frame on the
pro and pro Max when Alpa revealed this
new titanium finish they made it seem
like it was very very strong however I
actually have a scratch on it after only
two weeks I don't even know how this
happened there's a scratch on the blue
finish and it sticks out like an isore
and that's probably because apparently
titanium is actually a softer metal than
stainless steel and of course they have
that special PVD coding which I guess is
notorious for scratching so you guys
have to really be careful and get
yourself a good case and even worse with
this new titanium finish it's been
fingerprint Madness I thought the
fingerprints would totally go away but
they are still here on the 15 Pro Models
and getting into number two one of the
big issues that many people have been
experiencing over the past couple of
weeks has been overheating some people
even showed that their phone stopped
charging because it was simply too hot
and people complained that they're
basically just going through Instagram
or whatever else even in the background
their phone is getting insanely hot now
ever since then Apple has finally
released an update and a lot of people
are saying it's been getting fixed and
some people even prior to that said that
they turned off background app refresh
for Instagram and that magically solved
all of the issues of course we do know
that the a17 Pro chip is a very hot chip
in some cases using 40% more power than
the
a16 which led to a lot of throttling in
gaming but since the update I've done
some testing and to my surprise I played
a bunch of games at Max brightness and
the display didn't even dim the
performance was just fine I'm actually
shocked at how well it's been working so
while overheating was an issue it does
seem like it's getting a lot better and
if if you're really worried about
overheating there's also the Razer phone
cooler which I have tested and it
seriously gets insanely cold down to 3°
C to basically stop your iPhone from
heat soaking and reducing FPS in games
especially those AAA titles that are
coming very soon so if you want to check
that out use the link down below now on
to problem number three we have an issue
with the main cameras the 48 megapixel
sensor on both the pro and the pro Max
and now the entire lineup have that new
sensor the issue is that when you get
too close to something like when you're
trying to scan a check or take a closeup
photo it automatically switches to the
ultra wide camera which can totally ruin
the quality and that's because this new
sensor has terrible minimum Focus
distance we actually did a comparison
between the 15 Pro 14 pro and 13 Pro and
the crazy thing was the 13 Pro 1 and all
of those closeup comparison tests so
that's a big issue that's happening with
these new 48 megapixel cameras and I
really hope that Apple can fix it in the
future now moving on to problem number
four of course we know that the pro Max
has the new 5x telephoto camera which is
absolutely amazing and you got to pay a
lot of extra cash to get it $200 more
for the pro Max compared to the iPhone
15 Pro of course you do get double the
storage which is nice so it's a $100
difference but when you're zooming in
between 3x and
4.9x the cheaper 15 Pro actually gives
you better photo quality that's because
you're skipping from literally the 1X
lens all the way up to 5x Optical so
everything in between is not as good as
on the pro of course they have the 2x
which kind of crops into the sensor and
it's really good on both of these but
between 3x and 4.9 the quality does go
down now onto problem number five
because of this new rounded Edge design
the entire iPhone 15 lineup is now
literally more fragile than it was
before multiple drop tests have shown
that the 15 lineup is fairing worse than
previous models basically cracking
faster and if you don't believe that it
actually makes sense because if you take
a look at the front glass because it now
curves around and it uses 2.5d glass
it's now more exposed and it's easier to
basically hit a Little Rock in the just
the right place and shatter the entire
display on both the front and the back
glass as well whereas previously with
the iPhone 14 13 and 12s you had the
metal that extended all the way to the
edge with the flat more sharp corners
and that would really protect the
display glass but now it is definitely
more fragile now moving on to problem
number six yes of course we do have the
new USBC Port which has been amazing and
it can actually charge other devices
like let's say your airpods your Apple
watch basically anything you want even
the Razor phone cooler which gets
insanely cold powered from the port
itself but there has been an issue that
people have experienced some people have
tried to charge their iPhone 15 Pro
using a battery Bank however the iPhone
was actually charging the battery Bank
doing it the wrong way so somebody came
back their iPhone was dead and their
battery bank had a higher charge which
is completely not what's supposed to
happen so basically the only solution
that they found at the moment was to try
to charge the iPhone via the usba a port
on the battery Bank if it has one to
avoid the direction going the wrong way
so hopefully Apple can fix this to make
sure that doesn't happen to anybody in
the future cuz they'll get screwed with
a dead iPhone for problem number seven
to my surprise the iPhone 15 Pro Max
which is supposed to be very strong
especially with the titanium frame is
the first iPhone in many years that
actually failed the benest from Jerry
rig everything yes you saw him try to
bend it and boom the glass shattered
apparently what happened is that Apple
removed a certain piece on the inside
kind of like a metal frame piece just on
the 15 Pro Max and then Jerry rig also
tested the 15 plus and it did not Bend
so it's only the pro Max that is having
this major issue and it's kind of a
little bit sad especially with the
titanium now for problem number eight we
have the regular iPhone 15 models and
guess what these are the most expensive
phones in the world that still have 60
htz displays this should not be a thing
in late 2023 this is ridiculous Apple
should have given us at least 90 HZ to
somewhat stay competitive now I know the
general public doesn't care that much
they might not even notice but in terms
of the specs and experience in
comparisons to other Android phones that
are much cheaper this is a big deal
what's basically happening is that Apple
lives in their own little world
pretending that the only phones that
exist are their iPhone 15s and 15 Pros
so they basically skimp out on some
regular 15 features in order to make the
Pro Models look good and yes that does
work to boost sales of the pros and then
of course we have problem number nine
which is once again the USBC Port but on
the regular 15 models the speeds are
insanely slow at 480 megabits per second
basically the slowest USBC port in
existence on an expensive $800 and $900
iPhone Apple probably did this just to
make the pros look a lot better and this
is very annoying even though not many
people actually use the port for
transferring it just sucks that they're
making this limitation and then finally
for problem number 10 we have the action
button on the new iPhone 15 Pro Models
and the big issue is that you can only
do one thing at a time even if you want
to toggle the silent mode you have to
basically go back and forth between your
customizable actions back to the silent
mode or I even found myself having to go
into the control center instead to
toggle silent mode because the action
button can only do one thing and I'd
rather have it do something more unique
and useful what Apple should have done
was enable some new features where you
can single tap for something like silent
mode double tap for something else and
then also tap and hold for another
action they should have gave us
flexibility like that so we could have
multiple things at once multiple actions
not just one at one time that would have
been so much better in terms of
functionality but they left us with just
one so there you guys go those are the
the top 10 problems after 2 weeks with
the entire iPhone 15 lineup let me know
which one you've personally experienced
and what annoys you down in the comment
section below and if you enjoy this
video subscribe above and check out one
of those two over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video